So now we will look at so called history
based predictors, which are trying to do well on things
like when we have an not take and take and
not take and take and repeating pattern. Or something like
two not takens followed by a taken and then again,
two not takens followed by a taken, et cetera. Again,
it's a repeating pattern. That even a two bit predictor
will miss predict the taken branch, so it's one term
miss predicted, and even more complicated pattern
based things. It's important to note that these
are really 100% predictable. These are repeating patterns,
once you figure out what the pattern is,
the branch becomes 100% predictable. It's just
that these branches are not predictable with simple
N-Bit counters. What we need is a predictor
that somehow learns the pattern really. And then
it becomes a very accurate predictor. How do we
learn the pattern? Well, we don't just look at what's
the majority outcome here. For example, here there is
no majority outcome at all. Here, not taken is the
majority outcome. But takens happen very frequently, so if
we just look at what's the majority behavior, we'll have
a lot of mispredictions. What we want to look at,
is the so called, history, of the branch. What were,
the latest so many outcomes? For example, if we have the not taken, taken, not
taken, taken, and so on behavior. Let's ignore the first one for now. And look
at this particular prediction here. What we
know, is that the previous outcome, was not
taken. And if we know what the pattern is, then we know that when the branch
has been not taken previously, our prediction should
be taken. And then here, the history says the
branch previously was taken, so our prediction should
be not taken. And, if you are doing it
this way, then you will be predicting correctly
every single time. So what we need to learn
is that under the history of not taken,
our decision should be taken. Under the history of
taken, our decision should be not taken. Let's now look at this NNT branch.
In that case we have not taken, not taken, taken, not taken, not taken,
taken. The history now, needs to consider the last two decisions. So when
see not taken, not taken, we should be predicting taken. When we see not taken,
taken as the previous two outcomes we should
predicting not taken. And when we see taken, not
taken, we should be predicting not taken. And
then we are back to not taken, not taken
history where we should be predicting taken. So
if we consider for different histories, different predictions, then
we will train our predictors so that for it,
for this history predicts one outcome for this history
predicts possibly another outcome for this history predicts a different outcome
and so on. And then this becomes a very predictable branch.